while trump-backed candidates are seeing
political success for supporting his
election lies today a member of Trump's
Inner Circle is facing a criminal probe
for efforts to overturn it Rudy Giuliani
is scheduled to appear before a grand
jury in Georgia later today which is
looking into attempts by former
president Trump and his allies to
interfere in the election and influence
the officials who were running it Jeff
begaze has followed that part of the
story he's in Atlanta this morning Jeff
good morning to you
good morning Giuliani has been informed
that he is a target of this
investigation imagine how daunting that
must be to know that and to then have to
walk into this Courthouse behind me we
know that Giuliani the former mayor of
New York City is going to show up here
today the question is how Cooperative
will he be
for weeks after the 2020 election Rudy
Giuliani LED efforts to keep former
president Trump in power by spreading
false accusations about widespread fraud
the recount being done in Georgia will
tell us nothing
because these fraudulent violence will
just be counted again these actions are
at the center of the special Grand
jury's probe in Georgia investigating
whether former president Trump and his
allies violated laws in trying to flip
the 2020 election results in the state
efforts addressed by the January 6
committee earlier this year nothing
irregular happened in the county and the
allegations made by Mr Giuliani were
false after learning he was a target of
the grand jury Giuliani claimed that he
was simply doing his job as Trump's
attorney when you start turning around
lawyers into defendants when they're
defending their clients we're starting
to live in a fascist State there is
worrying signs if if you are Giuliani or
representing Giuliani that that a
prosecution might be in his future legal
experts say the grand jury could
possibly be building a broader case that
might implicate the former president
Bernie Giuliani unlike other folks uh
was part of some like decision-making
processes behind the the attempt to
overturn the 2020 election and that
suggests to me that the D.A is
potentially pursuing some kind of
conspiracy-based charge
meanwhile according to the associated
president another member of the Trump
legal team is being ordered to testify
before this special grand jury you don't
want to be a you don't have to have a
legal degree to figure out that the D.A
here Bonnie Willis is working towards
something a lot of people believe she's
working toward the former president
Nate
Jeff thank you